now the second tricky question is part a
now some of you are like that wasn't a
tricky question okay
if you if you know the answers don't
spoil everyone else okay so a lot of you
said
yeah i recognize this question i've done
these to death the limit
blah blah blah i know what this um this
sign
on x or i could have made 10 or whatever
okay i know what to do here
i need this 2x to be the same on the top
and the bottom so you're like cool i'll
put a 2 there
i'll put a 2 there it's 2 right because
this limit is one
right right
okay so so you got caught if you didn't
read the question okay because
most of us our brain you know pavlov's
dog that kind of thing
you see sign on x so whatever on x and
um
you start going into an automatic sort
of mechanical procedure okay
so if you missed out that the limits
approaching infinity
okay you would have just written this
down and you'd be dead wrong
okay so what does it mean that we're
approaching infinity and not zero
okay and this is not a result that
you're expected to memorize but you
ought to be able to think about it okay
if i gave you for instance um y equals
one over x
nice simple graph now you know what this
looks like right so if i said well let's
apply a limit to it
okay you'd all right away say
zero okay now you can say zero because
you know what one over x looks like
right
but how do you argue like what's the
logic that explains why it approaches
zero
and the answer is what you have on the
top is basic is a constant
it's a constant you have a constant b
divided by something that's getting
bigger
okay so it's going to get the whole
thing the fraction is going to get
smaller and smaller as well
okay um if i were to flip it upside down
if i had some other kind of
limit as x approaching if i gave you
this for instance
okay you've got the same thing on the
denominator it's growing
but it's growing at a linear rate a
constant rate okay whereas this is
growing
at an increasing rate right it's a
parabola yeah so that's why this is
going to be equal to x
okay you can do the cancelling you can
see so how do you apply that logic of
limits and ratios to this kind of
question
right which one is this more similar to
this one when you compare those two
yeah it's more similar to this one now
we don't quite have a constant
up the top do we but we've got something
that's pretty close to a constant right
because how does side
x sine 2x sine 3x how does it behave
it's um it looks like this right and
it's always between
these boundaries okay so it's not
constant but it's like a constant in
that it's never going to get bigger than
that
okay or or smaller
and i'm dividing by something which is
increasing okay
so the denominator is going to take over
and it's just equal to zero
okay so this is what i mean read the
question carefully don't just go into um
go on autopilot now it's not by accident
but this is in question one
right because question one is where
you're like okay just got into the
example
um your brain's not really switched on
so you make you make silly errors like
this
and they look pretty okay it looks it
looks
you know it's only one mark you're
probably not going to come back and look
at it and check right
but that's that's exactly what we're
checking for you to do come back and
have a look question one is where
um you know ninety percent of people's
silly errors come from because
the brain's not in here
so if you wrote down two without
thinking then please fix it yeah
okay now can you just sub in infinity no
because infinity is not a number it's an
idea
it's this is this concept of going as
far as you possibly can but
it doesn't have a meaningful numerical
value okay
as opposed to zero like when you've got
when we did first principles
for instance if you're doing this
this is how you differentiate the square
root of x by first principles
right uh sorry that should be negative
in this case h has a meaning right once
you rationalize the numerator
i am actually going to sub 0 in because
0 is a number
infinity you can't do it did i just
realize
if you have a slide right and you put in
like a really really huge number
you can't handle it yeah
yeah so then if you come in how would
you show work
how many marks is this question
justified
if they said justify well how did i
justify it
right i argued from the nature of what
sine 2x is
uh maybe that it's well seriously you
guys haven't talked about that
yeah it's bounded basically that's
that's the idea it's between minus one
and one it'll never grow
at some point whereas x is unbound it
just grows forever and gets bigger and
bigger and bigger
therefore the denominator will take over
in terms of importance and that's why
see that's the way